aquí dice la feria de ciencias tiene
experimentos de volcán imanes y moldes
esta gráfica de barras muestra cuántos
experimentos de cada uno hay en la feria
entonces veamos veamos esta gráfica de
barras nos dice que hay ocho
experimentos de volcán nos dice que hay
dos experimentos de imanes y nos dice
que hay cuatro experimentos de moldes
luego nos pregunta cuántos experimentos
hay en total entonces para saber la
respuesta vamos a contar el total de
experimentos que hay hay ocho
experimentos de volcán más dos
experimentos de imanes más cuatro
experimentos de moldes entonces ocho más
dos más cuatro será el total de
experimentos que hay
entonces 824 será el total de
experimentos que hay esto da un total de
14 experimentos y los podemos contar
aquí serían de volcán 12345678 + 2 de
imanes 910 + 4 de moldes 11 12 13 14 14
experimentos en total
hagamos otro ejemplo
este ejercicio dice el frasco de
galletas tiene galletas de azúcar avena
y chispas de chocolate esta gráfica de
barras muestra cuántas galletas de cada
una hay en el frasco entonces la
pregunta es cuántas galletas hay en
total
como en el ejercicio anterior vamos a
contar el total de galletas entonces
tenemos 6 galletas de azúcar 4 galletas
de avena y 9 galletas de chispas de
chocolate
el total sería 649 entonces 64 esos 10
más 9 19
entonces
19 es el total de galletas que hay
hagamos otro ejemplo los dulces en el
tazón son rojos amarillos o verdes esta
gráfica de barras muestra cuántos dulces
de cada color hay en el tazón
y la pregunta es cuántos dulces son
verdes bueno pues tenemos aquí
6 dulces rojos 9 amarillos y 3 verdes
la información que nos sirve es saber
que hay tres dulces verdes porque la
pregunta dice cuántos dulces son verdes
entonces hay tres dulces verdes
correcto y terminamos